what I'm not saying this show has
particular Powers but a few weeks ago I
interviewed a young man who came on and
was very impressive on Piers Morgan
uncensored and the next thing he's
running for U.S presidents and he's
running really as the first properly
anti-woke president of the United States
entrepreneur and author David ramaswamy
is a self-declared America First
conservative running for the Republican
nomination he's promised to defend
America against what he calls the
secular religion of workers which we've
just been talking about so welcome back
uh Vivek great to see you was it was it
the appearing on Piers Morgan uncensored
that drove you to announce your
candidature
I think it must have been just a
subconscious urge you gave me that's
right I didn't realize until you
mentioned it there but but it must have
played a role well listen good to see
you it's exciting uh you running I think
you've energized the race and it'd be
very interesting to see how far you can
take it the great elephant in the room
in every sense of course is Donald Trump
and the recent Fox News poll yesterday
showed Trump with a massive lead even
over his his second uh Place person Ron
DeSantis and then a huge gap back to the
rest of the field including yourself how
can you Barrel your way past Donald
Trump to win the nomination
so I view myself as building on the
foundation that he already laid taking
America first to the next level but I
say this very clearly appears in order
to put America first we in this country
have to ReDiscover what America is and
if you ask most people my age in the
country today really any age in the
country today what does it mean to be an
American today you get a blank stare in
response and the Hallmark of my
candidacy is that I'm Reviving the
ideals that set this nation into motion
250 years ago from your side of the pond
set this nation in motion not only 250
years ago but ideals that Define it
today basic ideas like Merit that you
get ahead in this country not in the
color of your skin but on the content of
your character and your contributions
free speech and open debate the radical
idea that the people who we elect to run
the government
ought to be the people who actually run
the government I think most people agree
on these basic rules of the road
regardless of partisan affiliation but
very few candidates are talking about
this issue of national identity and
that's what the heart of my campaign is
all about is Reviving this missing
national identity in America my travels
of this country suggest that people are
hungry for it they're starved for it and
so far I'm beginning by saying the
things that other candidates are not
willing to say in polite company but
which are just fundamentally true from
ridding ourselves of the cancer of
race-based affirmative action to
abandoning this climate religion that
shackles the West while leaving China
untouched and I think people know deep
in their bones these things are true
need to be said and most importantly
need to be delivered talking of truth I
was in New York last week and
interviewed George Santos this
Republican congressman who has told so
many lies it's impossible to keep up
with him and eventually I just put it to
him that he might just be a terrible
liar here's a clip
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
kind of stunning that to what you're
serving U.S congressman just brazenly
admit I'm a terrible liar and still sit
there
serving the American people it might be
it might be the most truthful thing he's
actually said and it might even be more
truthful than many other politicians
actually so the irony is that you know I
don't give him a lot of credit for much
but I give him credit for saying that
because there's a lot of other people
peers who are sitting in Washington DC
who could call themselves terrible Liars
too and I think that that's part of why
bluntly I respected Donald Trump for
what he did coming in as an outsider in
2015. you only get to be an outsider
once though I'm coming in as a new
Outsider as far as I know I'm the only
real Outsider in this race and you know
what at a certain point you become a
creature of the very swamp that you
wanted to drain you become a creature of
the government that you wanted to reform
I'm coming in with an agenda to do
something that I haven't heard from
other candidates shut these agencies
down so I've already committed to
shutting down the Federal Department of
Education in the United States it has no
reason to exist other than to cause
greater problems and spend money I'm
going to identify a list of other
agencies we intend to shut down to I
want to fire over half the federal
employees I've think that that would be
good for the federal government not just
in terms of saving money but restoring
Democratic Integrity that is speaking
truth but you know what maybe after
eight years on the job I'll be like one
of them too which is a good reason why I
need to get the heck out of the way but
right now is just a fresh perspective
and Shake It Up listen I think you've
got a very Dynamic style a very Dynamic
message don't agree with everything you
say but I I like the way you say it all
but you still not really address the
original question the elephant in the
room because to achieve any of the
things you're talking about you've
actually got to win the Republican
nomination that will give you the chance
to then potentially win the White House
and be president and do the things you
want to do and as you know Donald Trump
still has this massive Stranglehold over
the Republican Party how are you going
to beat it because I've known Trump a
long time right in good times and bad
we've had great friendship we've fallen
out a few times always fall back in is
fine but the thing about Trump is you're
either all in or you're all out there's
no sitting in the middle there's no like
you know what I like the guy but I still
want to beat him if you want to beat him
you've got to say how you're going to do
it and he's going to come after you you
know that
so so I'm going after this on the
substance peers and I I traveled to Iowa
and New Hampshire those are the early
voting States here in the United States
I had many people who came in there was
actually one elderly woman but many she
was caught on camera but many others
said the same thing which is you know I
want I liked what you had to say maybe I
want to see be Trump's VP now I'm moving
to you why was that because it was
because of the specificity of what I
said I'm going to deliver and just take
this example of affirmative action right
most Republicans hate affirmative action
as do I but very few have done anything
about it and it was because of a Lyndon
Johnson executive order in America that
mandated race-based quotas in the
private sector for any company that did
business with the government every
Republican president Donald Trump
included could have taken a pen and
crossed it out they chose not to for
fear of political backlash I don't have
that fear and so in a certain way I
think what I'm going to be my candidacy
is going to be defined by the substance
and specificity okay
by looking backwards and complaining all
right you have age on your side clearly
of your young Dynamic persons that's
said Nikki Haley one of your other
Rivals now running for the Republican
ticket she says effectively Donald Trump
and Joe Biden are too old it's time for
a new generation do you share that view
so I don't quite share Nikki Haley's
view because I don't believe in
eliminating the competition if you want
to be the leader of the Free World you
do it by convincing the voters of the
merits of your vision over somebody
else's she picked 75 arbitrarily because
Donald Trump's 76 if Trump had been 71
she would have said 70. I think frankly
that's a pretty lame approach to
actually try to eliminate competition I
think we should have it out in the open
have the open brawl debate it out in the
open and I think that the best ideas and
the best candidate to carry those
forward ideas will win and I'm running
because I believe I'm that candidate so
you believe you're worried about Trump
so because yeah the bigger threat you
become the more Trump will come for you
we've seen it with Ron DeSantis who he
calls Ron super silly as whatever it is
uh is your message to Donald Trump if
he's watching I'm sure he is he's a big
fan of Piers Morgan uncensored if he's
watching is your message that you're
going to beat him
my message is I'm going to win this
election because I wouldn't run for
president of the United States if I
didn't intend to see this all the way so
you're going to beat Donald Trump
look down the barrel and say Donald I'm
going to beat you
I believe that's what I'm doing that's
what I'm setting out on this election
I mean talk to you we'll stay friends
after I mean talk directly to Donald
Trump imagine he's watching which I
think he will be just say say to him
what that you're going to beat him
I love your energy man I love what
you've done for this country you were an
inspiration to what you did in 2015 now
it's my turn we're taking this forward
and Reviving America something you care
about something that I care about and
hopefully we can work together to do it
in some way because it's going to take
every one of us to revive this nation
and I'll tell you this too okay to be
really honest about it if you can't
handle some name-calling I see other
Republican candidates whining about this
possibility if you can't handle being
called a name in this country you
probably shouldn't be the person
representing this country sitting across
the table from Xi Jinping we all need to
toughen up a little bit and I think that
all of us do genuinely care about this
country I'm running because I I believe
that in all seriousness and joking aside
peers I care about this thing called
National unity in the United States and
I think Donald Trump is misunderstood I
think he cares about National Unity a
lot too even though people misunderstand
that about him but the question is who
can actually deliver it right now and I
think that if it was going to have been
delivered it would have happened already
we need a different approach to uniting
this if you're going to win if you're
going to win visit I've got to wrap it
sadly because I love talking to you but
um if you're going to win
are you suggesting then that maybe Trump
could be your running mate
I would take him as an advisor you know
what I would take his advice on
reforming the administrative State I
want to shut down those agencies he has
some experience trying I want to benefit
from his experience so I'll take his
advice at every step of the way I bar in
this primary I'm gonna thoroughly enjoy
that's what I'm running I'm going to
thoroughly enjoy telling Donald Trump
that you have kindly offered to employ
him as one of your advisors uh Vivek
ramaswami you're an excited advice is
what I would say thank you you're an
exciting candidate I'm glad you're in
the race I think it's what it needs a
bit of energy and dynamism and it'd be
very interesting to see how far you go
but it's great to have got to know you
on the show please come back again soon
appreciate it man actually final
question Viva Before I Let You Go
final question should James Bond books
be censored
no it's a hard note to that answer okay
got a double 07 answer to that question
it's sort of like uh you know take aim
at whatever that problem is and uh and
and really say we're done with
censorship in this country on both sides
of the Atlanta I like a straight answer
to a straight question thank you very
much
thanks man
interesting character